loisirs grand public les cinémas font
partie de la liste des commerces qui
doivent baisser le rideau à 21h alors
que leur clientèle vient principalement
le soir une dure réalité pour les
directeurs du ciné cet élan cours dont
j'étais à surprise d'apprendre ça comme
ça donc on est en pleine réaction en
pleine réorganisation évidemment dans
tous les cinémas concernés par ce
couvre-feu
donc moi je pense qu'effectivement bac
on va rajouter des séances phares on va
supprimer les sens de 20 heures autre
solution envisagée décaler les séances
plutôt et les organiser de manière à ce
que les dernières soit aux alentours de
19 heures à peine le temps de prendre
une boisson à la sortie du cinéma
les restaurants et bars sont aussi
concernés par cette mesure ça va être
compliqué moi ça on verra on verra pas
qu'à partir de de la semaine prochaine
comment sans mal géré et comment seront
les gens s'ils s'y seront toujours
présentes et dans le domaine du sport se
couvre feu entraîne une réorganisation
des séances et des horaires
d'entraînement le soir pour l'ensemble
des clubs évinois comme au rugby club de
versailles les conséquences sont surtout
organisationnel avec l'avancée de tous
les horaires d'entraînement notamment
pour les seniors et les juniors qui
s'entraînait jusqu'à 21h30 au 20h30
évidemment avant c'est désormais à 19
heures pour terminer à 20h15 20h30 grand
maximum et pour que tout le monde soit
rentré chez soi à 21h même si certains
sports ont déjà anticipé la nouvelle
pour les associations et les salles de
spectacles des discussions sont encore
en cours au sein du gouvernement